if you bias some of those processes you
can sort of bias what comes out of the
Crypt cryptography approach the
encryption process and you can get to a
stage where you could actually start to
attack that and you can see kind of
things leaking out and then you work
your way backwards so there's different
types of mathematics that are use in it
you do a computation involving the data
you want to encrypt and a secret of some
kind and either you need the same secret
to decrypt it and that's symmetric
cryptography or you can have a different
key to decrypt it and that's
asymmetrical public key retreat where
you have one key that you can use to
encrypt stuff which you might make
public and then you have a private key
that you can then use to decrypt stuff
and you so you can't decrypt using the
public key all banks have similar
numbers when you want to send them your
credit card details this is not a secret
number in fact your computer will
download this number when it wants to
send your credit card details so you can
put your public key out there other
people that I encrypt messages and send
them to you and you're the only person
with the private key so you're the only
person that can decrypt them there's the
computations that are actually carried
out to encrypt and decrypt and that's
the mathematics as I understand it
that's not been broken yet the
mathematics is still valid but there are
other pieces there that can be attacked
so you can attack the keys you can try
and get the keys in some some fashion
and that will allow you to decrypt the
messages you can try and attack the
people in the system so you can hold a
cost to someone's head and say oh you
know the Whitehead or something it's a
right give me the keys otherwise
somebody gets it but you can attack the
standards bodies that define how these
mathematical techniques are turned into
algorithms that actually make a
cryptosystem and if you can weaken the
way that that standardization that the
standards that come out of that if you
can weaken those then you can kind of
leave holes in it that you know how to
exploit you can do things where you
weaken specific components used in
systems built around these mathematical
techniques the mathematics as far as we
know is ok something little bits around
it you need so this a bit like I've got
17 locks on the front door but he's
showing
yeah so you go in the window or you pull
the wall down you can find other ways in
correctly implementing the mathematics
in a piece of computer code it's
actually quite hard to do because it can
be quite hard to write that code so
you're not leaking information you don't
intend to there are ways that the
information can leak out to this process
which lets you attack and get back to
the source message which is really what
you want to do I showmanship have a
magician where he's done the trick
before you even get something where it
looks like it's do you know the sleight
of hand thing is a bit more maybe what
they're doing the standards committees
already getting the weakness in right at
the start or getting the weakness into a
particular implementation that then
becomes popularly used that's believed
to be a correct implementation use it as
if it's a correct implementation but
there's this underlying weakness that
you're aware of you can attack that
weakness see kind of leave holes for you
to get some leverage later is there I'm
going to make it play itself out casting
to film wargames yes number of players
zero there was that back door where you
could play tic-tac-toe on the NORAD
nuclear simulator computer and that's a
sort of a thing that was left behind you
can do similar things that are perhaps
less obvious you know biasing a random
number generator to generate in a
particular way or picking one that you
know to be biased when they're
implemented correctly these systems are
strong but it's quite hard to implement
them absolutely correctly essentially
what you're doing when you encrypt
something is you're taking something you
know turning into something that just
looks like noise it just looks like junk
and what you want is to have no easy way
for somebody to analyze that noise I'm
kind of reverse back to what what the
original message was if you never use a
network you can't be traced through that
network use trusted implementations of
strong encryption where you can't that
have been you know probably open source
implementations so that they've been
well examined by experts and use them
carefully following all the guidelines
which typically means there is actually
a kind of a human cost involved it's
typically more awkward than not using
the right you're gonna have to take some
time to learn how to use them a lot I'm
not very easy to use and so on so you
just kinda have to put up with that
though if you really care it sort of
depends on how much you care there's
always a kind of cost trade-off here of
how much do you really care and how much
are you willing to put in to make sure
that that's the case you can protect
yourself against and you know an idle
observer pretty easily
protecting yourself 100% against you
NSA is going to be a lot more effort
from my own point of view I use you know
fairly standard mechanisms to protect
things like access to my bank details
and retailing online and so on where I'm
not really that bothered if somebody in
the NSA can tell ya that because they
can probably find that out for any
number of means and they really care - I
just probably believe they don't really
care - on the other hand there may be
some things where I do care a bit more
and so I would think about doing that
more or I might just think about not
transmitting it over the internet and
doing it through some of the main
meeting face to face or certain letter
something like that but again those can
be intercepted all these kind of
communication method can be intercepted
at some level that different levels of
the cost you know the trade-off there
becomes complex
I guess mathematics is trustworthy I
suppose when you try and turn it into a
working system there's lots of pitfalls
and of course you can never be quite
sure right maybe they did break their
maths
yeah who knows maybe they're just not
admitted that maybe the NSA go across
some computer stuff exactly I think he
knows these are secret organizations
type a key and it sends some numbers and
the same letter comes out the other side
but the news done realize a lot over and
over again it originally created
addictive onyx but oh dear our flash
drives let's remember what they do